ROBERT KUBIS: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Building Scalable
Apps with Cloud
Firestore, then stay tuned
because here is the Rewind.
When it comes to
application development,
I don't want to deal with
building and maintaining
infrastructure.
Do you?
Cloud Firestore and
Firebase platform
lets you focus on
building your application
while Google Cloud is taking
care of the infrastructure.
We believe this enables small
teams to accomplish big things
with powerful yet simple tools.
This starts with the choice of
a wide range of Firebase SDKs
for Android, iOS, and
web to connect directly
to Cloud Firestore.
The integration
with Firebase Auth
lets you setup authentication
and user management
in an easy way and integrates
with our declarative security
rules language.
That allows you to control
access to your data,
not only based on the user but
also on the information that's
stored in your database.
For storing and serving
your static content,
you can use Firebase Hosting.
And finally, to run
server side logic
and expand into other
services on Google Cloud,
Cloud Firestore is integrated
with Cloud Functions.
But we don't stop there.
Cloud Firestore is not just
a database for mobile and web
applications.
We also offer a full suite
of server client libraries
including libraries for C
Sharp, Go, Java, Python, and PHP
to enable powerful and more
complex backend applications.
Next, Dennis talks about what
is new of Cloud Firestore.
First, there are a
lot of new locations
that are rolling
out throughout 2019,
so you can store your data
closest to your users.
Second, there is
a Datastore mode.
Datastore mode allows you to
use your existing applications
built with Cloud
Datastore client libraries
on Cloud Firestore.
And the best thing, your
existing applications
are going to be upgraded
from Cloud Datastore
seamlessly with no downtime
once Cloud Firestore graduates
to general availability.
As a side note here,
this will probably
be the biggest
live data migration
with no downtime in history.
Third, we are removing
many of the Cloud Datastore
restrictions.
No more one write per
second per entity group.
No more Ancestor Only
Queries for consistency.
You now gets strong consistency
across all your data
and complex queries.
And no more 25 entity groups
per transaction limitation.
Fourth, there are a lot of
new tools and services coming.
Fully managed
exports and imports
to and from cloud
storage seamless imports
of your backups into BigQuery
to enable further analytics,
and a flexible index
management from the UI
and many, many,
many more things.
One more word on the
Datastore versus native mode.
Cloud Firestore can be used
in these two different modes
but not at the same time.
So you need to make
a choice upfront.
Datastore mode is used for
backwards compatibility
and high writes
throughput applications,
whereas native mode is
best used as a backend
as a service for mobile
and web applications,
which allows you
for synchronization
of state between
multiple devices
up to millions of
concurrent users.
If you want to know how
some of our customers
are using Cloud
Firestore, then learn
from Guesswork who built ML
[INAUDIBLE] e-commerce platform
on Cloud Firestore to
help companies like Zalora
with product recommendations.
Or Hawken Dynamics,
which focuses
on analyzing sports performance
with hardware and software
to optimize athletic
performance.
And finally, Notary, who
built the Next 2018 conference
website and mobile app
using Cloud Firestore.
All of these use
cases give insights
into their architecture
and best practices
using Cloud Firestore.
The second half
of the talk dives
into notable, awesome,
and exciting demos shown
and walked through by Cloud
Firestore to engineer Kathy Li.
So please check that out.
So if this sparked
your interest,
please watch the full talk.
Links are in the
description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]